[Music]
welcome back to the gingely podcast
we're so excited today we have a special
guest on this show a really special yet
really special guys how excited are you
right now
yeah we're it's happening we got a very
special guest today but first this
episode is brought to you by wink guys
well I go to the store and pick out wine
when you can just have blink deliver it
for you that's literally the coolest
thing in the world
okay so right now if you go to wink or
try wing talk I'm Sto I winc comm slash
ana and Julian there's an and in there
don't forget the end you get 20 bucks
off your first shipment check it out
they curate the wines they get your
taste did you get that to get your taste
based on your color or your palate
profile quiz that you take and then they
send you delicious wine okay right now
check it out also guys brought to you by
tracker the new tracker pixel is a tiny
device that's gonna make your day so
much better when you lose your items it
tracks your devices you attach it to
your backpack your wallet your phone
whatever you lose off and your dog and
it tracks to your tracker device on your
app on your phone so that you never lose
your important things it's incredible
peace of mind right now when you go to
the tracker that's th e gr ACK are calm
/schedule you get 20% off and you get a
30-day money-back guarantee it is an
incredible holiday gift to give your
loved ones I'm telling you you just give
it all your family just get them
different colors or whatever and say hey
now you're not gonna lose your other
gifts that other people got you but this
is the more important one because
otherwise you would have lost that gift
and lastly brought to you by nature box
guys if you're trying to eat better
especially during the holidays nature
box has got you covered they have over a
hundred snacks constantly changing and
evolving but always delicious guys made
with high-quality simple ingredients no
artificial flavors colors or sweeteners
right now go to nature box comments na
ture Bo XCOM slash annejulien for 50%
off your first order they have vegan and
gluten-free options
trust us we love it every time I send us
a box to show in the podcast we eat it
all before the podcast
Oh God
it's like all gone so in about a couple
minutes we are going to be speaking live
via the magic of the internet with the
hostess with the mostess the trap Trebek
Scott Rogowski the host of hu trivia the
quiz khalifa scott where gauss key has
agreed to do an interview with us on the
Jenna Dewan podcast of course he lives
in New York and he's literally working
all the [ __ ] time on being the host
of HQ so he's he can't make it here
until maybe next year which if he's in
town we'll get him here but for now he
agreed to do a Skype interview and we're
so excited about that I can't wait I
mean we told you guys however many weeks
ago I started playing HQ we were super
excited about it about the app you guys
have been spamming the word Inc in the
comments I even made a dink joke yeah
and we're really excited it's gonna be
really fun so Julian has like the real
questions and I got all the Darby
questions okay yeah and for those who
have been completely under a rock HQ
trivia is a live trivia app that you
play on your phone for the past at least
month or so probably about around a
month maybe a little more almost every
day they have a show at noon and it's 6
p.m. Pacific where you play trivia on
your phone and one of the more popular
things to happen out of this app has
been Scott Rogowski the host because
he's so charismatic
he's so internet e and really funny he's
talented he does a great job hosting
he's an absolute goof but he for
something he's got this it thing this it
factor that has really taken the
internet by storm so we're really
excited to talk to him he's gonna be
talking to us in just a second so yeah
that's the podcast today so get ready
we've never get good I know we never get
casted but we needed sky hey Jenna
Angelina and Scott podcast guys today's
the Scott popke podcasting Scott cast
Scott is the Scott cast we here the
Scott it's not even gonna be s it's just
him
we just blur out our faces on the call
alright well without further ado guys
here is HQ trivia host Scott Rogowski
thank you Scott for joining us on and
welcome to the Jenny Lee podcast I'm
Jana it's great to be here
tough to meet you nice to meet you Scott
yeah nice to meet Thanks the head Dinks
yeah you've met you've met so many dicks
and Chad now you're you're speaking with
the head Dinks there's so many things
just thank you guys I mean things have
taken over is it from Spaceballs ding
ding ding ding ding ding ding ding
you know I wish we had a cool story like
that but it's pretty it's pretty dumb
right like I'm sorry it's just our intro
music and how we sing it it's like ding
ding that's it that's the story of the
name you got a very large family the
dink fan yeah they are pretty awesome
yeah and they were all who play HQ huge
fans of you which is really cool because
I feel like the same could be said about
many many people right now but we're
really interested in how the whole thing
started for you as like the host I know
you made content and you still do you
know outside of HQ and you're the host
of your show the running Late Show but
how did it was there an audition or was
there sort of like how did it happen for
you yeah there was an audition I don't
do many auditions I don't get asked to
audition very often I've done like a few
commercials I think there was some
Gillette commercial where I had to take
my shirt off in front of a director and
four other people in the room that was
very uncomfortable for me did not get
that job but then saw the commercial
when it came out like oh yeah that guy
has a much better body than I do and
obviously he should have gotten it yeah
I was this for maybe like for
commercials in my life and then I tried
I got broad city auditions a couple of
those no no dice they're red oaks
on Amazon nada so yeah very few
auditions this one thankfully I did well
I guess I don't know I always think I
sort of do well on editions I hate the
process but my hoping is because I don't
do very many I go in and I just don't
care like this
like you know what I mean who cares my
goodness Gillette commercial you know
it's not gonna change my life so I just
actually got a callback on that one
which was amazing so I mean just just
getting a callback to me he's like oh my
god you know for a guy who doesn't set
often but for this one it was um hey we
got this trivia app thing we're working
on and think he'd be good for it so I
was like trivia app show what you know I
had no concept of it really until I got
there and kind of got more of the
download and then I was like oh man this
actually could be a really big thing I
didn't think it would be this big this
quickly but after talking with the
founders and talking with the team and
you know thankfully they like me for you
know they saw a bunch of people I think
and it's just been a really great
natural fit in terms of what I do and
what they what they're looking for and
what they're you know they want the
voice of the act to be yeah it really is
like the first of its kind like we
talked about how there really isn't
anything like I mean the closest thing
is twitch right it's like live
interactive game the rest is on your
phone you don't really have to
understand the platform it's literally
just right there for you
after a firt you know the first few
handful of episodes that you did or not
episodes or shows live shows did you
feel like it was gonna take off was it
like was there some sort of special
moment where you were like okay this
could be actually really big or was it
just kind of like all the sudden it
happened yeah I mean you know we were we
were in beta for a while and it was very
small you know started with just I think
the eight people in the office the first
show at eight people and then you know
we were kind of building up to like 40
people and others some tech people
started to get involved we people
inviting I sent all my friends I spend
all my friends the the beta link like
hey download this thing I'm doing of
course no one whites who cares why
thought I was just nuts but it just
slowly built and it's the kind of thing
that's very natural organic
word-of-mouth like people saw it they
dug it they told their friends about it
their friends tell their friends and
just the definition of virality right
like one person sells five people those
five people tell five people each and it
just exponentially grows but it was yeah
I guess it would be around we had a
thousand people and once we cracked you
know to the thousand I'm like okay you
know a thousand people that's a lot of
people
I kept putting in terms of how many
shows I've done I've cuz I've done
hundreds of comedy shows my life and the
audience's have never been a forum for a
thousand people before even so rule
that's a lot of them and it became two
thousand five dozen you know just kept
growing and growing there and then I got
recognized when we were about a thousand
people I was having dinner with my
cousins on in that little outdoor spot
and some guy walking down he's like
you're Scott from HQ right yeah how are
you people in the world playing this day
how am I being recognized you know right
now so that was that was a moment where
I'm like people actually care about this
and they you know they did enough to
like know who I am remember my name
because that's a big thing to most
people don't even HQ guy I still get
that now right now you're all the way up
to over 300 K is the highest DK we've
got I don't know when you can release
this but tonight's game you guys have
heard yeah yeah this release this
episode goes up tomorrow so it'll be
after that so but we are really excited
I can't I can't believe it's $10,000 I'm
excited it's probably gonna reach a new
peak ski Scott I'm very worried about
you
are you okay you work all the time yeah
very
are you eating okay are you sleeping are
you tired I'm that's thank you for being
concerned because I need someone in my
life that could feel concerned about me
might be my parents are on a cruise
right now for the panel for their m.i.a
no one's asking if I'm okay yes I'm not
sleeping great I'm not in a regular
schedule I have like a turkey and
provolone sandwich at 12:30 last night
that was my dip after midnight I'm
eating that was not good but I've lost
about ten pounds in last two months yeah
it's it's actually taking it's all on me
a little bit I do need a vacation but
you can't stop when I don't want to you
never think of it yeah so I enjoy doing
it and as much as if its whole as its
taking
I could definitely use a couple days off
to decompress but I enjoy it and I don't
want to stop I want to just keep riding
this thing see how high we can take it
yeah Scott you just had a birthday happy
birthday you're you turned sort of the
same age as me
you're technically a millennial no how's
life as a Sagittarius Scott I I consider
myself a Bob Saget Arius first
sensibility but life is a sad what is it
the guy on the horse with the arable is
it's gonna be a trivia question yeah is
that gonna be a new jersey that was a
horse on an arrow
I've got a few arrows in my quiver um
I'm uh just like knocking down
pedestrians okay like according to the
Chinese zodiac I was born in the year of
the rat yeah hey but if you look at the
Hebrew calendar I was born in the year
of the coupon so I don't know when you
were just a little Scott what did little
Scott want to be when little Scott grew
up little Scott wanted to be so many
things
I guess starting with like a
paleontology obviously we all love
dinosaurs as a kid I love digging for
rocks and stuff finding fossils I was
obsessed with fossil collecting and I
would crack these geode in the backyard
you know just I would easily just be
cracking rocks hoping to find a geode
didn't really ever find it had a tumblr
had the little thing where they like you
buy the kit and they put the rocks in
the sand and you just you know oh my god
I found a marble course you're gonna
find the rocks the things they're
Occident Wow you surprised anybody but I
did that I tumbled rocks I and then I
stamp collecting I I'm like how can I
make a career in stamp luck you can
so I put that to the side but then of
course baseball I wanted to be a
professional baseball player I just
wanted to get a baseball card that's all
I wanted to have my face on the baseball
card I wanted to get drafted by a team
in the 58th round I didn't care
just sign me to a contract on five
hundred dollar contract I'll playing the
rookie ball league and you know what
positions you play Wow you know into
high school I played first base third
face I was captain my senior baseball
team and I Corps and you know I was the
lightest hitting first baseman you'll
ever meet
I mean look at the shows I've no upper
bodies did you get on base than that's
all that matters
I was a scrappy hitter I was kind of
like I would poke something through the
middle or find the hole somewhere but
very slow I was five seconds to first
base I got clocked a five second my
might my coach said like get the piano
off your back come on I'm the slowest
the worst runner I went to speed camp in
high school to try to improve my running
that's how bad it got like speed camp
two weeks learning how to run properly
like how you thinking I'm using you got
to chop the air like this
apparently I remember that but now I I'm
not good enough to play baseball
professionally I never really had career
aspirations for anything I went to
college thinking like yeah I'll just be
a Poli Sci major like you know by the
weigh-ins yeah you know just the best
glory I got into for college was I
didn't really consider the whole college
search very carefully or seriously and
this is the best school I got into and
you know my advisors like yeah just go
you'd be stupid not to go and then um I
went but really even going into freshman
year of college I had no idea what I was
going to do I just thought it'd be my
dad was a lawyer my mom's a lawyer my
grandfather's a lawyer I'm the first
person in my family not to go to law
school that's an accomplishment yeah
Congrats to that so I ended up doing
comedy sophomore year of college I took
this comedy course and that sort of
changed trajectory of my of my life in a
way that's kind of a good segue because
I I'm curious like going from that world
of like comedy and also you're running
late show which you did post you know
and you still I think you still post on
YouTube a lot of your sketches and stuff
but going from the comedy and sketch
comedy world
and everything about it to kind of this
giant spotlight of HQ which is a
different part of the internet right
it's like a different medium it's a
different audience a different size
audience and it's a different format on
you know entirely what is what is the
transition between spots on the internet
been like for you you know you guys are
soaked in the internet and I consider
myself such an outsider like I you know
I've known about jenna Marbles for a
long time YouTube star blogger yeah
Julie my life Julianne but Jenna he's
for that don't worry you know and I just
II know who I talk with like these are
people I just remember reading about
when I was like you sorry this is when
you live in New York City you get
constant emergencies happening again
podcast with Jenna and Julian over they
don't receive every hearing our
ambulance yeah so uh no I don't even
know that there are different segments
there but I just always thought okay
YouTube is a thing I'll I started making
YouTube videos in 2009 which I guess is
relatively early but never did vlogging
never even cared to like get that deep
into it I just thought I'm not
interesting enough to talk in front of a
computer all day I don't know why people
want to watch that I'm amazed people do
like even watch people do that now and
twitch blows my mind who's watching
could play video games why a time that
which is the future Scott you need to
get on it right now
it's really fun of all the things to
watch someone do you need it
video game yourself just it's background
noise it's like it's theirs
it's really hard to describe when you're
watching a twist shame you're just like
you're it's a weird live interactive
background noise that you like to have
and when we play it it's nice to just
like play video games but not just alone
we get to like you know have people
interact with us about our playing it's
like a bunch of backseat gamers
basically yeah I just I mean I never
been a gamer to begin with so I don't
get that aspect of it like I watched I
guess I watch sports on TV you know
that's similar to watch you can argue
why would you watch baseball game you're
not playing the game why would you watch
baseball yeah I kind of come around to
that element of it if you're a gamer you
like games you're gonna want to watch
people play games but to me it's just
the most sedentary thing you can
I mean I did not even play but playing
video games is bad enough for me like
down for two hours and play a game at
least you're involved make a step
towards watch someone else playing what
the [ __ ] are doing sorry for the foul
line this year but I get animated
I'm gonna lose all my gamer fans after
this no I get it in a way I respect you
do what you wanted to your life but also
I understand how foreign it looks I mean
trust me or anyone any when we first
started twitch we thought the same thing
like what is this but we just wanted to
try it out and it turned out to be you
know a really cool thing and I think
it's growing for a lot of reasons not
just the gaming I think they have like
IRL which is you know like in real life
like people just live streaming sort of
like live vlogging but yeah I think I
think just the live aspect of twitch is
what I pass which is why I think HQ
works so well because it's that tune in
and live thing there's a FOMO element I
don't want to miss I got a tune in three
o'clock to 9 o'clock and you know now
I'm actually reading articles about the
NBA looking to twitch other sports
leagues are looking to twitch and saying
well we should incorporate that it's how
we broadcast our games you know it's
yeah and like even you know they started
broadcasting games on Twitter now like
you know Thursday Night Football
sometimes on Twitter but alive on
Twitter have you seen that I I you know
again I'm the worst consumer I don't
yeah yeah so yeah yeah Scott's busy he
works yeah I know I don't need to watch
you ready for this this is gonna this is
gonna cause a stir on the Internet
I have seen the wire never seen Breaking
Bad never seen Mad Men I mean I've seen
like clips and episodes here and there
but I haven't had time to watch these
all the way through so this is prestige
television I'm missing out on I haven't
seen I haven't read most of the great
books that have been written like I
haven't seen you know what's a good
movie I don't know I haven't seen a
located I haven't you know you're
talking to the master of not seeing
important things that I need to see to
be cultural and cultured right now and
today I haven't seen so many movies that
she gives me [ __ ] for all the time I
don't care I'm busy watching other stuff
I'm busy you know re watching this [ __ ]
I've already watched I haven't seen
neighbors or neighbors too
what am I gonna do it you're busy you
got something going yeah but no I yeah I
didn't this moment in my life I'm like
focused on producing and creating stuff
and then I figure when I'm 80 I'll have
time to watch everything that's ever
been made let's see no I guess that's a
good mindset I mean yeah like you said
you can't really stop right now you can
stop right now when I'm like an invalid
lying in bed somewhere part of me like
almost wishes like let me get into a car
accident let me just be strong so I just
have six months in a hospital just to
watch all this stuff that I've been
missing on up right just one really long
flight around the world yes yeah just
get an Amtrak around the country
well there I mean there really is no
offseason do you do you foresee I know
you mentioned like you might be out in
LA coming up a little bit but do you met
do you see a break foreseeable break in
HQ you know for you yeah you know not
really I see that um yeah it's hard to
even comment on that because I don't
know what the future holds in terms of
you know scheduling and you know at this
point it's been like I'm doing HQ when I
have another gig that I'm I'll begin to
do or I have a wedding in Boston I have
to go to like that's what I'm not doing
HQ I basically been doing it everyday
I'm around there's never been a day
where I'm yeah I'm just not doing
anything today I'm off so I'm not gonna
do HQ know if I'm around here and I'm
available to work I'm working so and I
don't mind that schedule so much but
after all this time now it and then then
with the press element coming into it
when it was just show up do the shows
now it's like show up to the shows get
interviewed by NBC get interviewed by
BuzzFeed go to giffy go to Jingle Ball
your time is taken up and then meet with
this perfect meet with that person you
know so that now it's becoming a lot to
handle but it's all good stuff I'm not
complaining it's all great and I'm very
happy where I am
of course do you have any other
questions yeah I do a while ago you
almost moved to Los Angeles
can you please still move to Lawson
my plan was really because I was doing
my running Late Show for I'm doing in
New York for six years I finally took it
out to LA for the first time last
February in May and had ten phenomenal
shows I got to interview the likes of
Joe Manganiello mr. mr. True Blood
himself mr. Magic Mike Joe Manganiello
Weird Al Yankovic hero of mine forever
Ben Schwartz Matt graining the creator
of The Simpsons Matt Groening Reggie
Watts you know all these amazing people
because they all live in LA so I please
you know Paul of Tompkins so I did ten
shows out there and I realized after
those last shows away I'm like you know
what Johnny Carson moved to LA from New
York I think if I'm gonna keep doing
this show and pursuing his late-night
comedy career I gotta move to LA maybe
get a weekly going build up the show
from scratch because I've been doing it
for so long I've done a lot of great
press here I felt like I sort of hit a
wall though you know I sort of guy I got
the time out in New York New York
Magazine New Yorker New York you know
ny1 had a profile I mean like I've
gotten great press here and it's just
hit a point where okay well why are we
gonna talk about this show anymore we've
already talked about it like to move to
a new market and get closer to the
talent pool and start from scratch so
that was my challenge I was gonna get
myself and I gave it my partner
Williamsburg I was all set to move but
then HQ came a knock and I thought let
me you know I didn't have a solid job
out let me give this a shot and loaned
olders the best decision I've ever made
Wow yeah but but hopefully at some point
because it is you know 30 degrees right
now and it was snowing all day yesterday
not that I don't I do like snow but what
is it 82 and sunny in LA right now it's
75 yeah yeah so perfect you know you
should green screen a beach behind you
but some yeah we you know what if you
want we will that's what we'll do then
you know we'll the beauty of the
Internet is you can work from everywhere
right you can you know work from LA work
from New York we don't want to take up
any more of your time dude thank you so
much for for doing this with us this is
really cool and just so you know are all
varieties huge fans of Scott from HQ so
I Oh tweets from I mean I've had more
tweets from the dink fan hashtag dink
fan what do you do enjoys bug-eyes one
either
I did it guys and truthfully I you know
it's according to say but obviously
anyone doing anything entertainment it
doesn't exist without the fan
interaction the audience oh thank you
for being fans of HQ thanks for playing
I don't hate gamers I don't if your
lifestyle like I I'm an older millennial
you know I missed I missed that for that
wave of digital Nativity but I get it I
appreciate it and thank you for wanting
me on the show and thank you guys rad of
course yeah we really appreciate it dude
get out there and I will see you tonight
at 6 p.m. yeah yeah all right thanks so
much guys see ya all right
Lag daddy himself has graced the gender
julián podcast that was so fun he's so
great he is a wonderful wonderful guest
he was really really nice I'm so glad
thank shouts out again to Scott for
agreeing to do this like the joke was
Jenna was like the concerned mother like
are you working too much but that man is
working I can't imagine the like when he
said you know we talked a little bit off
off-camera after the interview and he
was saying you know just talking about
we were talking about his war schedule
and like when you think about the amount
of hours it's not an insane amount hours
but it's the way his schedule is formed
yeah and it's all on the show yet but in
the fact that it's live and like that
growing amount of number I mean it's
it's an insane gig if you think about it
and he's [ __ ] killing it in the live
is hard it's just hard and like you talk
about like twitch it's which compared to
that I feel like it's pretty easy cuz
you're gaming you're not you're not
running a show yeah and there's no
outtakes like you were your life and he
[ __ ] he thinks on his feet you know
he's the true step professional and that
was really dope I really enjoyed talking
to him yeah he's a really cool guy
and I mean whatever happens with HQ in
the future I hope that it go everything
goes great it's a really fun [ __ ]
great thing to play but most importantly
I think that Scott I hope that he's
happy and I hope
he gets to do whatever he wants for the
rest of his [ __ ] life man he's a cool
guy he took a chance on it's a scary
business decision it's a risk you know
to take this job and to do this and you
know it's it's paying off for him and I
just hope that he gets to do whatever he
wants he has even a bigger hand and in
the show because so much of it really is
him you know yeah yeah and he seems like
he's really quickly like I mean I hope
he gets handsomely paid yeah well
hopefully that's all you know but hope
you know all we can say is like from
talking to him for the amount of time to
talk to him it does seem like he's
enjoying the internet from someone who
didn't really know much about the
internet before that yeah and that's
cool and I think I remember like the
first couple of times I played I was
like I like this guy yeah and like
normally I don't like that guy I don't
like the host of this whatever I always
think it's like too corny or like to try
Hardy to be Mimi or whatever and I'm
just like he's great like he's and he's
natural and like I think he's when I
asked him about like transitioning from
the comedy and like this get the skin
side of YouTube to like this side or not
you did the internet rather sorry what
was that like because it's seamless and
I feel like you did it so well he
transitioned into being like like family
friendly so to speak but I like also
just comedy that everyone can understand
I think he's done a really good job of
it yeah I mean he's a fascinating person
and um it's it's just [ __ ] cool the
whole thing is really cool hysterical as
a person so yeah like magical he's quick
on his feet
Chris Mel burger the person that told us
about HQ because Chris and chin and
snake were all we were here for torch
con and just like Scott said that's how
it traveled they were like download this
app and I'm like what is it what is it
we were just watching them or like what
are you doing
we're playing live okay
I'm doubt we all play yeah but it
traveled via word of mouth and Chris has
actually seen Scott live and was like
yeah dude he's [ __ ] funny yeah
Scott is very fun yeah and I didn't even
know he was like a comedian when I was
playing me out because I was playing it
after jujitsu one day in in the studio
or in sorry in the Academy I was playing
on my phone and a couple of my teen
Ian's came up and they're like oh yeah
that guy's funny and I thought was like
well I thought they were like he's funny
right now like what he said was funny
girls like wait how does like no I
watched his [ __ ] he's funny I was like
oh he I didn't realize I had no idea
really cool shouts out to Scott Reed ask
you guys you can follow him out Scott
Rogowski on Twitter make sure you that
was one of my questions literally I had
a bunch of questions I didn't ask him
obviously he's gonna have enough time so
I made sure I asked him how life was as
the Sagittarius you know yeah I had to
get what would what do you want for
Hanukkah is there anything the Internet
can get you for Hanukkah so for for
Hanukkah maybe 400 kilos God given that
young follow you will appreciate it
because we had the interview we're gonna
do a little bit of a late sponsor II but
you know what let's end the show with
some beautiful do you want to maybe like
I don't know play something yeah let's
get some vibes going on movie just some
sponsors let's hang out for the last
couple minutes and you know what would
really make this snack this great this
time greatest next is naturebox I'm
tired sorry naturebox guys they have
delicious snacks waiting on this music
if you're trying to eat better
especially your in the holidays the
cookies are on the table you don't want
to eat them this is scary music what are
you talking about
I'm scared anyway let naturebox help you
during the holiday it's called the
morning walk it's a scary walk where are
we going
no no I don't want to listen the
beginning I've heard it it's a piano
nature fox.com / Jenna Julian that's
what your popcorn boy over a hundred
delicious snacks with high quality
simple ingredients guys no artificial
colors flavors or sweeteners guys to get
snacking it's so easy you just go to
naturebox.com/tyler Julian to get 50%
off that's messing with my headphones I
don't know why but then they will send
snacks right to your front door they
deliver them to you you don't have to go
shopping you just get the snacks and you
eat it like Jenna said sriracha popcorn
is our current favorite right now
guys check it out 50% off right now they
have Kung Pao pretzels coconut cashews
am i making your mouth water hopefully I
am also guys when you're done snacking
make sure you sign up for wink at try
wink calm slash Jenna and Julian week is
a wine delivery service when you take a
pallet profile quiz online they ask you
about flavors you like what specific
taste you enjoy mate and that's
completely specific to you and then they
send you wine that is fit for your
palate they customize the wine they
curate the wine they are specialists and
they send it G to your front door you
don't have to go shopping you don't have
to be lost in the store trying to pick
the coolest looking wine bottle it's
just the one that is scientifically for
you okay wink is a really great service
Kermit do you like wink guys shipping is
also complimentary so you don't have to
cover shipping that's you don't have to
cover gas to the store it just shows up
at your front door they will cover
shipping and if you don't like a bottle
they send you they'll replace it with
another bottle how great is that
try wink comm slash Jenna and Julian has
T ry winc $20 off and they will cover
the shipping and lastly guys don't lose
your beloved possessions and make your
family have the peace of mind I'm not
losing their Christmas gifts with the
tracker
how does the tracker work it's a tiny
coin size device okay you download the
app and the GPS tracks from the app on
your phone to the device itself you can
put it on your backpack you can put it
on your dog you can put it on your drone
you can put it anywhere you think you
might lose something and you will always
have the peace of mind of finding it
when you lose your device when you lose
your device or your item you just go
into the tracker app and you can find it
via GPS on the map and you can even make
it make a noise so you can find it
within a lost pile of laundry in your
room where you can't find your [ __ ] and
if you lose your phone but you have the
tracker you can look at your phone with
the tracker you can reverse find it's
very easy it is incredible
30-day money-back guarantee but you will
not need that guys go to the tracker
comm s th e TR ACK r slash Jenna Julian
for 20% off or click the link in the
description and get all your family the
peace of mind that they did not think to
buy this Christmas or Hanukkah Thank You
tracker and thank you sponsors and
lastly Thank You Jenna for that
beautiful music and dancing during the
podcast oh my god he's falling asleep to
it well that was a fun one that was
really fun it was a fun one thank you
guys for hanging out for the podcast we
hope you enjoyed this Scott rodowsky
interview listen guys okay he gets
interviewed by actual press and
important people and he took the time
out of his day to come be on this
podcast just because the ding fam has
been so strong in the comments you guys
have been spanning him on Twitter and
you know what it's it's just [ __ ] rad
you guys are rad thank you for allowing
this to happen so that we could talk to
Scott cuz he's a really cool guy and you
know what I just I hope that Scott has a
happy life so basically yeah because he
deserves it I agree right yep shout out
to Scott and we'll see you guys next
week for another podcast I think right
I heard the first Barnes commercial on
the radio I was like losing my [ __ ] was
like Barnes something firm from an old
podcast we just thought we just ended
the show with an inside joke that's
Jenna's fault no it's my fault stuck on
you so I love you so much for that you
have no idea what I was saying is we're
streaming on it's a lot more of us and
you're not getting enough from Jenna and
her videos are my vlogs go to our twitch
channel twitch TV slash Jenna Julianne
we're streaming all the time playing a
lot of pub G doing a lot of fun things
so hang out over there but thank you
guys for hanging out with us another
week we'll see you guys next week for
another podcast and stay fresh mates
cuties whoa [ __ ]
fighting what are those finger guns Oh
Oh what is that
[Music]
you
[Music]